problem was that wasn't no proof this
reminds me of like water boy or
something yeah you know now that I I
practice
now that I practice in Virginia a lot oh
I actually run into stuff like this on
occasion
hey league today we are reacting to an
episode of Bob's Burgers called a few
Gert men and I'm not alone I'm joined by
none other than law by Mike yup it's two
lawyers one
bummer two lawyers one
Bob's Burgers Jane breakfast yum sorry I
took so long but I think you'll agree it
was worth the wait so what are your
thoughts on suit jacket but shorts oh
the uh the short suit look definitely
not gonna fly in court I mean it's very
breathable though do you take your pants
and then cut them or do they actually
come that way tailored uh I mean you can
always convert any really high priced
suit into uh shorts it's almost as bad I
think the worst I've ever seen like it
wasn't me personally seeing it but was
someone who wore the jersey that they
were allegedly uh stole no you see that
viral video yeah it's supposedly like
stole this Sports Jersey and they wore
it to court right you're charged
with stealing a dolphin Jersey
that's uh I mean look it's
circumstantial evidence yeah he's a very
strong circumstances not the best look
for for all you people out there if
you're going to court dress as best as
you can even if you have to borrow a
suit borrow a suit do not show up to
court wearing casual clothes the judges
hate that and it will hurt your case
even though it's not supposed to
indochim
do you think we should make a fashion
line of a suit shorts if someone would
buy it
what do you guys think out there should
we have a legal ego law by Mike short
brand
I'm gonna pass on that yeah why are you
wearing your fancy clothes Jane's all
dressed up for the school-wide mock
trial he's the big tough prosecutor all
right right I'm a Sharp Dressed silver
tongue devil not in those shorts
that is kind of video Sharp Dressed do
you ever use mock trial as a kid uh I
didn't do mock trial
um I did do you know some trial practice
in my Law Firm but what about you uh I
did Montreal basically every year
starting in middle school middle school
yeah I mean I did mock trial for I don't
know like 12 years or something I was
always really excited as a kid either
doing mock trial or debate and like
getting to dress up Fancy with a suit
and tie I still get I mean that's why I
never take this thing off
yeah it was back in the day when uh Ali
McBeal was popular so it was like the
the big fashion statement was pink tie
pink metallic tie with like pink shirt
or like purple metallic tie with purple
shirt that was the big stuff back then
this sounds as bad as the shorts
Danny's going up against Louise The
Savvy defense lawyer it's Belcher
against Belcher we win either way we'll
see right there though you got Belcher
versus Belcher so two siblings going
against each other uh yeah is that is
that an ethical violation well under ABA
rules you have to get consent from your
clients because there is a little bit of
a concern if you know the other party's
lawyer maybe you're going to give some
information away if you have some
relationship and we can't forget the
most important role of all Tina the
juror with great jury comes great
responsibility so you definitely can't
have a family member on the jury yes I
mean that so I mean we talk about
peremptory challenges versus challenges
for cause a lot and voidir I have to
imagine that would be an automatic four
card challenge I wish I could sit on the
jury and zone out while we do a mock
trial of Snow White whoa do you think
the evil queen gave snow light up please
an apple yeah
yeah for a jury of her peers to decide
but probably it's just those babies in
high school I also participated in a
mock trial in my English class I think
which is what they're doing here I think
it was Antigone um so we read the Greek
play yeah
that doesn't make any sense because
Antigone commits suicide so I don't
think we would have put her on trial for
that
um King Creon said oh that's what it was
don't bury the body of polynices and she
did this is a really
esoteric issue that we're dealing with
here how many viewers out there uh know
this story thank you for tuning in to
Legal Antiquities uh we're gonna be
covering all of Sophocles plays uh it's
a completely new channel legal BC
legally you'll be seated now that we
have one viewer left let's I guess get
on with Bob's Burgers okay everyone
judge Conklin is just outside and he's
ready to begin he's retired but today
he's gonna hear our case and guide us
through the process bailiff Zeke why
don't you get us started hear ye hear ye
the court of the honorable Judge Conklin
is now in session I like how he has a
cut off yeah maybe you should call me
the somewhat respectable judge Conklin
he's funny somewhat wet and messy George
Conklin I had a little accident just
water not pee Oh God this guy's got no
filter please stated so what's your
policy on making jokes in the courtroom
oh definitely wouldn't do it I'm never
at all I mean yeah I I try to stray away
from it obviously you can understand how
the judges depending on if it's your
first time seeing the judge I always
take the more conservative approach you
know if the other side is doing silly
stuff or things that are making the
judge Angry let them go off on them yeah
of course yeah and I think we can both
agree the policy is that when the judge
makes the joke you laughing oh You Gotta
Laugh really hard like you got it's a
funny joke you've ever heard never in my
life if I heard anything funny the best
joke judge should be a stand-up comedian
your honor ladies and gentlemen of the
jury here are the facts the evil queen
was jealous of my client the gorgeous
but a little Sun wouldn't kill her Snow
White and gave her a poison apple
sending her into a sleeping death to sum
it up not cool so do your thing and
return a verdict of guilty okay pretty
argumentative for an opening statement
oh yeah yeah you can't you can't have
argumentative portions in your opening
statements
um and not cool I mean yeah it's pretty
much an argument right there if you ask
me
you're supposed to tell the jury what is
going to come out you're supposed to
proffer what the Witnesses are going to
say and maybe at the end you might say
and because of this evidence we will ask
you to return a verdict of guilty at the
end of the trial we save the arguments
for closing after the jury has seen all
the evidence and then you can argue why
that evidence proves your point yep it's
opening statements not opening arguments
exactly okay
thank you okay well that was even worse
than the first one
yeah that was pretty bad I mean at that
point one thing that most people don't
realize that you can and often should do
is just reserve your opening statement
until after the prosecution's case in
Chief so that you can craft your opening
statement to respond to their points and
craft your entire case you know
sometimes it's better to know what
you're going against especially because
the jury uh you know usually forgets
what you say by the time you go and have
to present your case they've already
forgotten your opening oh yeah the the
recency effect is absolutely real no one
will remember what the prosecution said
days and days ago so to be able to give
an opening statement much later in the
case can be a huge Advantage yeah what
was that
okay
I'm a little slow today
her first name
so
swimming Prince huh yes I am and what
kind of charmer goes around kissing dead
girls I mean presumably the prosecution
had to call the witness and then she's
being she's Crossing yeah the sweetness
right right yeah so she's allowed to ask
leading questions so leading questions
are allowed when you're cross-examining
a um you know adverse witness which this
person would be because like you were
saying uh prosecution probably brought
them up as a direct witness but when
it's the other side they can't do it
because it's almost like spoon feeding
them and one trick to get around that is
if you're directing a witness and it's
your witness basically all you have to
do is say and what happened next uh yeah
if you're ever stuck just ask and what
happened after that get off my back how
many corpses did you kiss before you
found your Snow White Romeo yeah
objection in there is the fact that
Prince Charming kissed a corpse and
arguably created all kinds of criminal
liability is that relevant to what he's
being questioned on here it's not it
doesn't go to the witness's veracity for
truth and it doesn't go towards the Evil
Queen's guilt exactly and it's also
super gross yeah it's very gross
now are you going somewhere with this
counselor no not really I just wanted to
upset the witness your honor looks like
you did it I did it yeah I don't think a
judge if first of all if a lawyer admits
that that was their purpose they're
probably going to be in uh you know some
sanction trouble I would imagine yeah
um most lawyers would at least try to
play it off like they weren't
intentionally trying to do it yeah do
not admit that you asked a whole bunch
of questions in bad faith yeah
um now that's not to say that lawyers
don't do this and try to get under the
skin of witnesses it's definitely a
tactic that is done but they're
certainly never going to admit it you
didn't hear it from me yeah not a good
lawyer if there are no further questions
it's time for the jury to deliberate all
right then I guess I ask for a mistrial
it's impossible for my client the evil
queen to get a fair trial here because
everyone knows the story of Snow White
huh no one has ever asked for a mistrial
it's an okay argument but if you're
going really what she's doing is not
asking for a mistrial so much as a
motion for change of venue and she
really should have made that motion
before the court proceeded although I do
Wonder like what venue can they go to
where they don't know the story of uh
Snow White you get a limiting
instruction from the judge it says don't
refer to her as the evil queen yeah that
should have definitely been done for
sure yeah an instruction would be
necessary and throughout the whole case
just referred to as the queen yeah or or
maybe her first name her first name is
evil instead of implying royalty or
something so you'll grant me one nope
the jury seems impartial and capable
jury how do you find the defendant the
impartial capable mysterious and
glamorous jury rules in favor of the
prosecution we find the evil queen
guilty shocking sweet lady Justice yeah
so I don't think Snow White would be a
particularly good piece of literature to
do a mock trial over because it's so
stacked against the defense yeah well
that's what's happening here right yeah
uh I mean what
what defense could you come up with for
the the evil queen here she she poisoned
Snow White and Insanity defense she
didn't know the difference between right
and wrong maybe I mean she's she's
although she thinks she's like mirror
mirror on right she is talking to Amir
though she maybe she is a little great
she claims to have a magic mirror that
can tell her who's the fairest in all
the lands yeah you'd have a really tough
time coming up with a defense for the
evil queen here yeah
DVD I don't know
I have to sleep on that one yeah
no I see what you did there yeah no I
didn't yes you did I did not what is
going on Mr Front stole my yogurt look
this is his trash can yes right I did
not eat that yogurt it's a crime of
passion fruit sounds like you need a
lawyer hey let's try this in student
Court we've already got a judge sounds
like you need a lawyer I know I know at
least in the personal injury area you
know someone gets an accident you can't
just run up and be like sounds like you
need a lawyer
um I I presume it's the same kind of
thing like if someone's dealing with the
legal issue lawyers can't just like
appear out of nowhere and be uh hey
here's my card yeah yeah you'd think so
I'm fine taking this to student court
let the whole school see that Mr frond
is a dirty yogurt Thief I am not a thief
I'd be happy to take this to student
Court what happens when you find Fran
guilty does this school have the death
penalty How about if the jury finds him
guilty he has to wear a sign all day
that says I'm a disco gusting yogurt
Thief ah yes and if he's found innocent
then you have to wear a sign all day
that reads I'm a filthy liar mouth so it
would be completely improper for uh the
plaintiff and defendant to conspire with
a judge to decide what the potential
outcome of this case is going to be but
it's kind of like arbitration where
they're just agreeing to the terms of
the arbitration or agreeing to
liquidated damages before going to
arbitration okay this gets much worse
and goes completely off the rails but
watch part two of this video over on law
by Mike's channel of course stay for the
grade for legal realism